hi Drew my name is Teresa and my husband
and I are huge fans we're currently
renovating our home and as somebody who
lives with severe asthma I wanted to ask
if you had any tips on what we can do
around our house to make it a little bit
more asthma friendly during the changing
of the seasons
well Teresa
and AstraZeneca to shed some light on
the things that we can all do around the
house I have to say studying for this I
got a lot of Illumination here to share
is an allergist Dr Pyle Gupta
so Dr guptak how can we help Teresa yes
so Teresa's question is actually really
timely because we're just coming off of
something called asthma peak week which
is a time when the when the country sees
its highest concentration of asthma
attacks so what is the first tip in the
line of defense that we can do because I
don't want to hear bad news I want to
hear what I'm supposed to do yep nope
absolutely and so
um the first is actually about our
clothes and our shoes Okay
um so when you first come in from the
outside you want to take off your shoes
and you want to change your clothes and
that's because our clothes and our shoes
track in pollen and other pollutants
that will then come into our indoor
space so in order to keep your indoor
space safe especially during Peak pollen
Seasons we really want to do these easy
things and those things make a big
difference they do yeah so the second
tip is about dust mites so dust mites
are are these tiny microscopic creatures
that are look at that thing look at that
that's an incentive incentives you to
get your act together nothing will
they live off of the flaking of our skin
and so we're not allergic to them but
we're allergic to their droppings so
so we can put a protective pillowcase on
our pillow is that right doctor so the
pillows I think are the most important
and you can get dust mite protective
covers for the entire bed but um that
that can get expensive and so um I
really like for people to just to know
that pillows are the most important
thing so if you choose your battles go
with pillow or if you really want to
spend some money
um protecting yourself against those
guys you could do the whole bed so the
other one is to wash your sheets in hot
water at least once a week not cold and
not warm why may I um it just gets rid
of the dust mites and the dust mite
droppings more effectively okay
um and so it's important this next and
final tip really spoke to me and there's
a solution for these ironically
Solutions
um tell me about products because that
can really affect people with asthma
yeah so you know the kitchen and the
bathroom are two places that we really
want to keep clean right and so we're
using kind of these harsh chemicals that
can really affect people with severe
asthma and so we want some tips for that
is to wear a mask while you're cleaning
okay um because that helps kind of
protect the Airways and then also to not
use products with fragrance so fragrance
less products so if you see on the label
fragrance free yeah is that what I
should be looking for yeah okay that's
what you look for that's very directive
I cannot thank you enough
and to everyone at home living with
asthma you should talk to your doctor to
discuss your unique symptoms and you can
also visit
breaktheosmocycle.com to find helpful
resources and better understand your
level of asthma control I have to say I
learned so much in this segment I feel
so empowered Dr Gupta thank you
[Music]